CAROLYN UJCIC: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting these
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Carolyn Ujcic.
And today, I'll
be talking to you
about how to start ML projects.
You can ask questions
any time on the platform,
and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
Let's get started.
So as I mentioned,
this presentation today
is around how to start
machine learning projects.
And it's called
"from hype to value."
Machine learning is a
big buzzword these days,
but how do you know
if you're selecting
the right project that will
justify your investment?
We'll tell you more about
how to do that today.
So our discussion for today
is going to just start around
the ML journey--
what it looks like.
What is that typical path
for companies like you?
Then, we'll talk about
use case identification
and qualification, which is an
important step in making sure
that you select a feasible
machine learning project.
We'll walk through
a few case studies.
And then at the end,
we'll have more time
for a question and answer.
So first, I want to
start by debunking
a bit of a myth about
machine learning.
I often hear this
from customers.
So you have some data.
That's your input.
You feed it into a
machine learning model.
That performs some
magic, and then you
get your answers,
or your output.
That's not actually
quite how it works.
So when you think
about machine learning,
you can replace the word
"magic" with "math."
So machine learning
fundamentally
is using math to
make predictions.
So let's talk a little bit
more about exactly what machine
learning is.
The way I think about
it is it's a way
to maximize the data
you already have.
And you're probably already
using it, or at least
collecting a lot of data.
So think about machine
learning in these three steps.
You have a large
quantity of data.
You apply a mathematical
algorithm to that data.
And then you get a
forward-looking prediction that
will help you make a decision.
Now, I want you to keep in
mind these three steps as you
think about how to apply machine
learning in your organization.
Sometimes, machine learning is
not always the best solution.
But when you're making
repeated decisions
and you have large
quantity of data,
then it can often be
a really great way
to get a competitive advantage.
So within Google Cloud, we
have a professional services
organization that helps a lot
of customers discover feasible,
high-impact ML use cases
for their companies.
And we really think about
this as involving these three
important parts.
First, is we want to
work closely with you
and your domain experts.
You know your business best.
And we're basically
here to guide you.
And this presentation
as well will hopefully
guide you as you're
thinking about how to start
ML in your organization.
The next step is
feasible, not magic.
So again, the fact that
machine learning is magic--
it's a bit of a myth.
So we really want to help you
qualify your machine learning
use cases and look at if
they're actually technically
feasible for your
organization based on the data
that you have.
The last part
involves making sure
that those use cases
are high impact--
so looking at things
like what sort of revenue
might be generated by this
machine learning use case.
Or what sort of
cost savings can we
expect if we were to complete
this machine learning project?
So we think about the
machine learning lifecycle
as having these 10 steps, and
it's an iterative process.
Today, we're going to really
focus on steps one and two.
But I'll walk you through
the end-to-end life cycle
so you have a sense of
what comes after you've
defined those ML use cases.
So, as I mentioned, today
we're focusing on ML use case
identification.
And that's the best place to
start for a machine learning
project.
You want to get very specific in
terms of what you're predicting
and what decisions
you're going to make.
So, for example, if
you're forecasting
sales for your
stores, you want to be
sure about exactly
what you're predicting.
Are you predicting sales for
each of your SKUs every week
or for the next 12 weeks
or for the next 52 weeks?
So you need to get
very specific in terms
of what you want to predict.
The next step involves
data exploration.
So during this step,
your data analyst
will perform exploratory
data analysis
to really understand your data.
What do you have?
Is it good quality?
How can we link together
your different data sets
so that we can use them in
the machine learning project?
We'll also try to look at
relationships between the data
as well as any signals
that might be missing
and how we might be able to
bring in some additional data
sets so we can
have those signals
and capture them in our
machine learning model.
Step three is around
selecting an algorithm.
And this often involves
research in the problem space
that you're working in.
So, for example, with that
sales forecasting idea,
you would want to do
some review of what
are some other successful
ML applications related
to sales forecasting.
What sort of models
are people using?
And there's a wealth
of information
out there that you can really
pull from so that you'll
know where to start.
After that, you get into your
data pipeline and feature
engineering.
During this step
is when you really
think about what are
those inputs that
are going into our
machine learning bottle.
So when you think
about those inputs,
you'll want to
consider, again, how
can you link them together into
a single record that will sort
of feed into that ML model?
You'll also want
to think about what
are the components of
that data pipeline.
And we call those features.
So, again, just think of those
as the inputs to the ML model.
But you can get
creative around how
you engineer those features.
So, for example, you might look
at the previous week's sales
for that sales
forecasting use case.
But maybe you'll also
look at same-store sales
from one year ago or maybe
sales in that geographic region
two years ago.
This is where you
can also start to be
creative with your external
data sets as well--
so things like weather.
You could pull in the average
temperature from the week
before.
Or if there were any
inclement weather conditions,
like a flood or a tornado,
that may impact sales as well.
Following that, you
code your ML model.
So this is where
your ML engineer
will come in and actually
create that machine learning
model that will be
making the predictions.
And often, this is a
very iterative process.
And that's why you see
step six listed here.
You actually go back and repeat.
You may tweak your data
pipeline and your features
and then see how
your model performs.
And then you may try it again
with some different features.
Or you may remove
some of the features
that you thought were important,
but maybe they aren't really
improving your ML model.
So again, keep in
mind that you're
going to iterate over and
over again on your ML model
until you get some results that
you think are meaningful to you
and your business.
And that's what follows--
step seven.
During this step,
it's important for you
to share those preliminary
results with your business
stakeholders so they can
really see what you've learned.
Oftentimes, we'll define
specific ML hypotheses
during an ML project.
And this is a
really exciting part
of the project
where you can share
if you proved those
hypotheses with your business
stakeholders.
So, for example, maybe
one of your hypotheses
were around weather has
an influence on our sales.
So at this point, you
probably have some data
that you can show to
prove or at least show
some preliminary
findings related
to some of those hypotheses.
Once you've gotten to
a level of success that
meets your business
needs, you can
start to plan for deployment.
And this step often
involves thinking
about the end-to-end
business process that's
affected by this ML model.
So before, we were just trying
to get those predictions right.
But now, we need to think
about system integration.
So is this going to be
part of maybe a forecasting
platform that you use today?
Does this need to be
integrated with some dashboard
that your executives look at?
So you'll need to come up with
a plan and the requirements
required for deployment.
After that, you actually
operationalize your model
into production.
And Google has a lot of
tools to help you do that.
And then you want to
monitor your model.
So over time, your model
actually needs to be retrained.
You actually need to continue
to teach it using new data,
because we all know
your business is going
to continue to grow and change.
So during the
monitor phase, you'll
want to come up with
some specific metrics
that you look at so you
can determine when you want
to do that retraining
or when you want
to maybe create a new ML model.
So monitoring those
metrics will be
important to know when should
you start that retraining
process or when should you maybe
start development on another ML
model.
So that's the end-to-end
machine learning life cycle.
Again, today, we're going to be
focused on steps one and two.
But hopefully, this
gives you a taste
of what the entire
process looks like.
So now, you might
be thinking, OK.
This sounds great,
but how do I do this?
Who needs to be involved?
Well, machine learning
is really a team sport.
It doesn't just involve that ML
engineer that we talked about.
There's actually a
variety of players
that you want to make
sure are engaged.
So these folks come
from different areas
of your business-- engineering,
analytics and science, and also
domain experts.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about some of the typical roles
that we see involved in these
machine learning projects.
And I want you to
think about who
you might be able to
bring into these roles
in your organization.
So the first is your project
sponsor or decision maker.
This is usually
a leader that has
some ownership of
the process that's
going to be impacted by ML,
someone who can really come up
with the success
criteria for the project
and can also decide
when something might be
ready to move into production.
The next person is
a domain expert.
So this is usually someone
who's doing the process today.
And this is someone
who is really involved
in perhaps making a
lot of human decisions
around the ML problem.
So for that sales
forecasting example,
it could be one of
your planners or one
of your financial
analysts who's actually
doing the forecasting today.
And we'd want to engage
with that person.
Understand, how are they
making their decision?
And how can we try to
get an ML model to think
about the problem in that way?
This is an interesting
opportunity, too,
to get ahead of some
change management needs
related to adoption of ML.
So this domain expert is
going to need to use this ML
model down the road.
And so engaging them
from the beginning,
really making the most of
their institutional knowledge,
will hopefully make
it easier for them
once you're actually deploying
the model into production
and you're asking
them to use it.
The third role that's important
to consider is a data analyst.
So we talked a lot about
the importance of data.
We're going to talk more about
how you look at it as you're
qualifying your ML use case.
This person will be involved
in assessing that data,
performing that
exploratory data analysis,
trying to understand
things like data quality.
Another role that's important
to include is the data engineer.
And this person
is really involved
in creating that data pipeline.
And, again, the pipeline
is what is ultimately
going to feed into your
machine learning model.
A solution architect is
also another important role
for an ML project.
That person is going
to help you come up
with your overarching solution
for deploying your ML model.
You know, I mention
sometimes there
are some technical
integrations that are needed.
And that solution
architect would
help define the
requirements and help
to understand those
integrations so that you can
have a successful deployment.
And then the last role to keep
in mind is the project manager.
So there's obviously a lot
of coordination involved
across these different roles and
throughout the ML life cycle.
And you need a project
manager to help orchestrate
all those different activities.
Now, it's often great
to think about someone
who has some experience in
more of an agile methodology
because, as I mentioned
before, there's
a lot of iterations
and repeating
that occurs in an ML project.
So you want someone
who's got that experience
and knows how to maintain
that flexibility,
even as they're trying to
manage a more complex project.
So I mentioned we're going to
focus on steps for use case
identification.
Here's the way we think
about it with our clients.
So first, we want you to
identify and prioritize
your top business challenges.
This will help to ensure
that your ML projects have
the greatest business impact.
So oftentimes, we'll
get people together,
and it'll be a mix
of stakeholders.
And we'll have them come up with
those top business challenges.
Following that,
once you've agreed
on what those top
business challenges are,
we want you to brainstorm
and get creative around ML
use cases that address those
top business challenges.
So sometimes, it's
thinking about what
decisions we need to make
over and over again that could
benefit from predictions.
Getting people
together and coming up
with a large quantity
of ML use cases
is a great way to do this.
And then, we often
have people vote
collaboratively to decide where
do we think we should start.
And that voting
helps us to come up
with a short list
of ML use cases
that we really do some
deeper qualification around.
So normally, we look at
about three to five use cases
that we'll hope to
put on our ML roadmap.
And step three involves
qualifying those use cases.
So we'll usually take a
deeper look at the data.
We'll talk more about
what we do there to assess
technical feasibility.
It's also good practice
to really quantify
the business impact
of the ML use cases,
again, so you can
make sure that you're
justifying your investment
in the ML project.
After that, you can create your
ML roadmap for development.
And we'll talk a little bit more
about how to do that later on.
So as you're starting to think
about ML and where to begin,
I want you to consider where
you are on this path to ML.
And this path is
really the journey
that any process or
product might go through
as it's maturing.
So I'm going to walk through
one example related to a contact
center or a support
team, but you
can think about any process
or product in the same way.
So if you have a
new contact center,
at first, you may receive
requests from customers.
And you may only have one
person answering the phone.
I know a lot of
startups begin this way.
But over time, as you get
more and more requests
from customers, you'll move out
of that individual contributor
phase and into the next step,
which is around delegation.
You might need a team of people
to respond to those customer
support requests.
And that is phase
two of delegation.
During this phase, there will
be a lot of standardization
that happens of your
business processes
so that anyone can
actually perform that role.
After that, we often
see customers move
into this digitization phase.
So this will be where you'll
maybe set up a ticketing system
to automate and help
digitize those support
requests, the
routing, the solution.
And this is an important
step because it really
liberates and starts to
collect a lot of the data
that in the past you
maybe weren't capturing
in any sort of meaningful way.
And over time, as you
acquire more and more data,
you move into this big
data and analytics phase.
And sometimes, you might stay
in this phase, and that's OK.
But sometimes, you may
want to do something
more sophisticated, again,
especially when you're
making repeated decisions.
So you might want to move into
this machine learning phase.
So with this contact
center example,
you may move into a phase
where you start automatically
routing and predicting
the types of issues
that customers have
based on their messages
that they're sending you.
So that's a very common use
case we see a lot of companies
implementing.
But in order to get
there, you really
have to make sure you're in that
big data and analytics phase,
that you're collecting
that large volume of data
that really is required for
any machine learning project.
So, again, consider where
you are on this path to ML
and how mature your business
process or product might be.
As you're thinking
about ML projects,
I also think it's good to be
realistic about the effort
that's required.
It's a little bit different
than your traditional software
implementation projects.
So think about these
four activities
that are involved-- defining
key performance indicators,
collecting data, building
infrastructure, and optimizing
your ML algorithm.
So a question for you--
what percent of time
and effort do you
think each of these steps take?
So what we often
hear from customers
is that their expectation is
very different than reality.
So you can see here, a lot of
people assume that optimizing
the ML algorithm-- that
big green bar on top--
is what really requires
a lot of time and effort.
But in practice, that's
actually not true.
You can see the
reality at the bottom.
The dark blue area
of collecting data
really takes quite a bit
of time for ML projects,
so you should expect that.
The other area that often takes
a lot of time with ML projects
is building infrastructure.
And that's represented by
that yellow bar at the bottom.
Now, Google Cloud
actually has done
a lot of the infrastructure
building for you.
So if you use some of
our managed services,
like Cloud Machine
Learning Engine,
we'll actually take care of
a lot of that effort for you.
So keep in mind this
ML effort allocation
as you're thinking
about your projects
and as you're doing
your planning.
You're really going to want
to invest a lot of time
in that data collection.
And I think you'll be surprised
how little time is actually
spent on optimizing the
specific ML algorithm.
So as I mentioned before,
data qualification
is a really important
step as you're
thinking about the feasibility
of your ML use cases.
So this is the list of
steps or a checklist
that you can use as you're
thinking about ML use cases
and you're trying to
assess their feasibility.
As I'm walking through
these, think about the data
that you have to support
your ML use cases
and how it might measure up.
So the very first step is
around assessing the feasibility
based on any data ownership
or practical considerations.
So, again, machine
learning projects
require large amounts of data.
And you want to make sure that
you have ownership of that data
so that you can use it
to build your ML model.
In many cases,
that's not an issue.
So for sales
forecasting, for example,
you probably own
a lot of that data
yourself if you're
managing the stores
where the sales are being made.
But sometimes, there
are other scenarios
where you don't own the data.
And that can sometimes
be a blocker.
So it's important to think about
those practical considerations.
The next step is around
collecting samples.
So once you've identified
your ML use case,
we want you to consider
all of the data
that you currently
collect that might
be used in an ML prediction.
So for the sales
forecasting example,
you may have historical
sales records
from all of your stores.
And you'll want to get
a sample of that data
as you're assessing the
feasibility of that use case.
You may also want to bring
in other data sets, though--
things like promotional data--
that have a really strong
impact on the problem as well.
So identify all those
different data sets.
And then collect the samples.
You can then hand
over those samples
to your data analyst who
will take a look at things
like data quality.
When I say data quality,
we're looking at things
like are there a lot
of missing values.
Is there a lot of constant
values in the data set itself?
That can really help us to
understand if the data is
good quality or not.
You also want to ensure
you have labeled data.
And this may be a new
concept for some of you,
but it's very critical for
machine learning projects.
So when I say labeled
data, you want
to have historical examples of
what you're trying to predict.
So, for example, with
sales forecasting,
you want those
historical sales records.
And if you're trying to
predict sales volume,
you need to understand
what that sales
volume has been in the past.
That data is used to train
the ML model to teach it.
So if you don't have
those labeled examples,
you won't have a way
to train your ML model.
You also want to verify that
your data sets are large enough
for model building.
So one of the reasons why
machine learning is gaining
so much steam these days
is because it has a lot
to do with all that big
data that's being collected
in many different industries.
So you want to
make sure, though,
that you have a
large enough volume
to perform well in these
machine learning projects.
Generally, the more data
you have, the better.
But when we're looking at
some of these deep learning
algorithms, the more
complex algorithms that
are based on the way
your brain works,
we often look for
data points that
are maybe in the hundreds of
thousands as a minimum to get
started.
So, again, you want
to take a closer look
at the data you
have and make sure
that you have a large
enough volume of data.
And lastly, you want to
check for class imbalance.
What is class imbalance?
Well, it just means
you need to have
enough positive and negative
examples or enough examples
of different categories that
relate to your machine learning
problem.
So, for example, I
worked with one customer
that was trying to
predict truck breakdowns.
And we needed to have
more examples of trucks
that had actually broken down.
In the initial data set,
they were collecting
a lot of data points.
But they only had 32 examples
of trucks that had broken down.
And that's an example
of that class imbalance.
You want to make sure you have
enough historical examples
of those trucks that
are functioning well
and the ones that
have broken down.
So, again, you can use
this as a checklist
to think about how does
your data measure up
for your machine
learning project.
So in this next slide, this
is an example of an output
that you might have as you're
going through this use case
identification process.
So on the left, you can see four
use cases that were identified.
So imagine we just
had a great workshop
with different stakeholders
across the business
and from our tech organization.
And we came up with
these four use cases
as a way of solving our
top business problem--
so things like cross sell, up
sell, customer-centric store
layouts, a recommendation
engine for online ordering,
and a chat bot to
support online orders.
So through our
qualification process,
we assessed the business impact
and technical feasibility
of each use case.
And on the right, you
see a nice visual summary
of that in this 2 by 2 matrix.
So you can see here,
some of these use cases
have a much higher
business impact,
like cross sell, up sell.
That definitely would have a
nice tie to increasing revenue.
But it's not quite as
feasible based on the data
that we looked at and the data
that we're collecting today.
So for our ML project, we
may want to actually begin
with use case three or four.
These still have a pretty
high business impact,
and they're much more usable.
So a recommendation engine for
online ordering or a chat bot
to support online orders
could be two places
where we could start.
Now I'm going to walk through
a few case studies that
show you how other businesses
are applying machine learning.
So Uniqlo is a
Japanese retailer that
operates close to 2,000
stores all around the world.
And they wanted to find ways
to make their customer shopping
experience easier
and more enjoyable.
They looked at some of their
top business challenges,
and those involved
things like the changing
retail environment.
We all know that the way that
we make purchases and we shop
is really changing quite a bit.
And they also wanted ways
to bridge the offline
and online shopping experience.
Uniqlo not only has many
stores around the world,
but they also have a pretty
awesome website where
you can buy things online.
But they didn't have a good
way to link those things.
So in terms of the
business impact,
they really saw some
pretty impressive results.
So they created a chat
bot that was integrated
with their mobile app.
And this chat bot
would provide answers
to common customer questions.
And these things ranged
from is this black sweater
available in the store that's
nearest me to what color
skirts do you have
available in this style.
And they really saw a great
improvement in engagement
as a result from this chat bot.
So of the users that
had the app, 40% of them
interacted with the chat
bot on a weekly basis--
40%.
So that's pretty impressive in
terms of engagement numbers.
So when you think
about the chat bot,
there's also some
great tools that we
have to accelerate development.
And so there's a great product
available called Dialogue
Flow-- this is available
through Google--
that really can make building
a chat bot faster and easier.
So if this use
case interests you,
I'd encourage you to
take a look at that.
This next case study is
around sales forecasting.
So we worked with a global
consumer products company,
and they were interested
in improving their sales
forecasts from
their distributors
to their retailers.
And there were a few
business challenges
that were identified that
they were hoping machine
learning would help them with.
So their existing process for
forecasting was very manual,
and it was very clunky.
So they were using a lot
of random spreadsheets
to generate forecasts.
They were also
collecting quite a bit
of data across
their organization,
but they weren't
really using it.
So they knew that they could
do better if they found ways
to harness some of this data
that they were collecting
today.
But they were really only
using a few data sets
around historical
sales and things
like important holidays
and events and seasonality.
So they also felt
they were missing
some really important
signals that
were relevant to the problem.
So they had a hunch that
weather, for example,
was very important in terms
of driving sales of some
of their products.
But till today, they didn't
really incorporate that
into their modeling.
So we worked with them to
create a custom ML model.
And the model actually
yielded a 15% improvement
in forecast accuracy.
And it was projected to
save them about $2 million--
so a pretty significant
business impact.
And this model was
interesting for them
because it incorporated quite a
few nontraditional data points,
like weather, demographic
information, and even
Google Trends information.
So machine learning is a great
way for you to think about some
of these external
data sets that might
be relevant to your
business problem
and really find ways
to incorporate them.
So this company, for
example, had been doing
a lot of statistical modeling.
And they were doing some
pretty sophisticated stuff,
but they weren't able
to incorporate some
of these other data points.
And with ML, they
were able to do that.
So I'll walk through the top
five tips that I have for you
before you start
your ML project.
So the first is around making
sure your use cases have
a high business impact.
Again, we want to make sure you
get the return on investment
for your ML project,
especially if you're just
getting started in this area.
So really quantify the revenue
and cost savings associated
with a specific ML project.
Get your hands around your
data to assess feasibility.
We walked through
that data checklist,
and it's very important that
you go through that for your ML
projects.
We also encourage you
to get samples of data
so you can really take a
closer look at data quality
and make sure that the
use case is feasible
based on all of that data that
you're already collecting.
Number three is
around being clear
about what decisions
you'll make with ML.
So remember back
to the beginning.
ML is all about
making predictions
that can help you make
better business decisions.
So think about what
those decisions are.
What does that process
look like today?
And then how can ML help make
those business decisions easier
or better or more accurate?
Once you've done
those things, you
should be able to
build a roadmap for ML.
And we encourage you to
start with quick wins.
What we've found is
that over time, you'll
adopt ML for one you
case, and then you'll
adopt it for maybe two
or three and that you'll
have an acceleration of using
ML in your organization.
It's actually what we've
seen at Google over time
as we've done more and more
ML within our products.
But in order to get started and
really generate some results,
we encourage you to
start with quick wins.
Going through that process will
help you to establish a team,
establish a model,
a way of working,
and also improve the quality
of your data for that use case
but even for another
ML use case as well.
And then finally, the last
thing I'll leave you with
is, remember, it's math.
It's not magic.
So stay tuned for
our live Q&A. We'll
be back in about a minute.
All right.
So we've got some
great questions
from our audience related
to starting ML projects.
So the first is "how is ML
different than big data?"
That's a great question.
We talked a lot about how
it's important to really
be at that big data
stage before you
can move into an ML project.
When you think about the
difference between ML
and big data, remember,
ML is about making
those forward-looking
predictions.
With big data,
you're really looking
at historical information.
And you're performing
analysis based
on those historical trends.
So big data I like to
think of and associate
with a live, real-time
dashboard where you're seeing
exactly what has just happened.
But, again, machine
learning is actually
all about thinking of
forward-looking predictions.
So, for example, big
data could tell you
what your sales were and trends
in sales for the past month.
But ML could tell you what
do we believe the sales will
be for next month.
OK.
The next question-- "who
needs to be involved
in defining ML use cases?"
So this is another
really important point
that I want to make
sure you understand.
So ML use case
definition is really
a cross-functional
collaboration.
You need to bring in
people from your business.
your data experts.
You want to bring in
your technology leaders
and your business sponsors.
So you really want to make sure
you have that diverse team.
There's also that
brainstorming step
that's involved with
defining the ML use cases.
And what we find is when you
have a more diverse team,
you'll often come up with many
more ideas and better ideas
at the end of that
brainstorming session.
So remember, you want to have
that very diverse team of folks
across your organization.
And we encourage you to think
about business and technology
and also different
levels-- so everyone
from maybe your senior
leaders, your directors, all
the way down to
that data analyst
who knows the data
really well and maybe
is really excited
about machine learning.
"How much data do you
need for an ML project?"
So this is another
good question.
We talked a lot about
how ML is really powered
by large quantities of data.
And in general, when we're
thinking about a deep learning
algorithms, a good
rule of thumb is
to think about having hundreds
of thousands of data points
as a starting point.
Now, there are some
nuances to that
that you may need to consider
for specific ML problems.
And that's where an ML
engineer can help as you're
thinking about those things.
But, again, we think that large
quantity of data is important.
What we also find is
the more data you have,
the better your ML
model will perform.
So, again, if you have
some pretty high bars
for your performance
of your ML model,
you really do want to
collect a lot of data--
as much data as possible.
That will really improve
that model's performance.
OK.
And the next question--
"how do you assess the business
impact of an ML use case?"
So for this one, we
talked a little bit
about two important ways of
looking at the ML use case.
You want to look at
the impact on revenue.
So is there a way that this ML
use case might substantially
increase revenue?
Or is there a way that
it will save costs
that you might have today?
So I would think about
those two things.
But in your organization, you
may have some standard ways
that you approach
creating a business case.
And ML is not any different
than other business cases
that you may have put
together in the past.
So you can also use any
sort of process or criteria
that you may have in your
company today when you're
building business cases
around other projects
or other investments.
So keep that in mind as you're
thinking about the business
impact of those ML use cases.
All right.
And then the last
question we have here
is "what are some
other examples of using
machine learning in retail?"
OK.
This is a really good one, too.
I think retail is a space
where there's a lot of ways
that ML can really
make a big impact.
So a few big high-level
categories to think about
are things like merchandising,
supply chain, pricing,
customer experience, as
well as digital insights.
So when I think about
those five different areas,
when we think about
things like merchandising,
how does ML play a role there?
Well, you can look at
things like predicting
trends that may affect
the stock that you
want to have in your stores.
Supply chain is
another great area
where ML can make a big impact.
So you can think about different
places in your supply chain
where you might want
to make predictions
that can optimize it--
so everything from
how do we want
to set our production sizes, to
what is our minimum inventory
level in the store,
to how can we
keep our shelves from
stocking out of items
that are in high demand.
I also mentioned the
customer experience.
There are a lot of ways
that ML can help there.
So you saw the one example
of a chat bot from Uniqlo.
But you can think of
other ways that ML
can improve the customer
experience, so things
like a recommendation engine.
This is a really great
quick win for a lot
of retail organizations-- so
looking maybe at your website
and looking at ways that you can
recommend products to customers
based on the data
that you may have
collected about their
shopping behavior in the past.
So the last area mentioned was
around the digital experience
and digital insights.
And, again, for those
online storefronts
that you might have,
you're probably
collecting a lot of data.
And you can think
about different ways
you can optimize that
experience for your customer
as they are shopping and
trying to make those purchasing
decisions.
All right.
So I think that wraps up all
of our questions for today.
So stay tuned for
the next session,
accelerate cloud adoption
using API management
as an abstraction layer.
[MUSIC PLAYING]